Good morning, John. Do you know what life
is? This question has always fascinated me.
I mean, at first, it seems like kind of a
simple question. Like, you're not dead, you're
alive. Pretty big difference there. When you're
dead, you're stinky, you're decomposing, you
turn--and you stop moving. It's pretty--it's
pretty clear.
But if you think about it for a long time,
it's not whether or not I'm alive or dead,
it's whether or not a virus is ever alive
or whether or not a computer virus is ever
alive. What about Johnny 5 and those little
things from Batteries Not Included? And if
you weren't alive in the 80s, what about GLaDOS?
If we don't have the definition, how will
we know when we've created something that's
alive? And does it really matter and is this
all just pseudo-intellectual navel-gazing?
Navel-gazing is a weird term. Staring into
your belly? Whoa. What is that?
So when I asked on Twitter, I got some funny
answers, but mostly what I got was a list
of criteria which appears to be what is being
taught in schools right now. Move, respire,
sense, reproduce, excrete, and nourish. First,
that is a list of criteria; it is not a definition.
Second, that list of criteria seems a little
bit unnecessarily restrictive to me. Like,
Lieutenant Commander Data? If you are a Star
Trek nerd, he doesn't respire, he doesn't
grow, he doesn't reproduce, but nonetheless,
he is alive, he's more than alive, he's sentient.
So my personal definition--this is the one
that I've come up with: life wants. If thing
x requires thing y in order to continue its
existence, and thing x shows attempts to acquire
thing y, then thing x, apparently wanting
thing y, is alive. A side note, if wanting
is in fact the fundamental attribute of what
makes things alive, I think it goes a long
to explaining why humans never seem to stop
wanting.
I mean, even if you got like twenty thing-a-mabobs,
you got whozits and whatzits galore, still...
Oh, I'm about to embarass myself, aren't I?
We want more!
The problem with the definition of "want"
is that it's fairly easy to create a computer
program that wants something. Like, Google
Search Bot, for example, wants to seek out
and search information and send it back. But
does that make Google software alive?
But beyond the biological definition, my favorite
definition of life is Schrödinger's. And
yes, Schrödinger, the dude with the cat.
So entropy is a physical, measurable physical
quantity, quality, like mass, or heat, you
know, and it's a measurement of disorganization.
As your entropy goes up, you become less organized.
My body, right here, from the strands of DNA
in the cells of my feet to my delightfully
tousled mop of hair is an extremely organized
sy--really organized, just tremendous amount
of organization. But the second law of thermodynamics
states that entropy must, as a rule, increase,
and the disorder of the universe will forever
increase.
What, then, is this? This magnificent, near-perfect,
amazingly organized meat that contains me?
Schrödinger said basically, I'm paraphrasing,
life is any system that continuously decreases
its own entropy using energy around it. Basically,
Schrödinger took a fundamental philosophical
question and answered it with an equation.
Which is just amazing.
But if life organizes itself using energy,
then Schrödinger's definition kinda is just
as bad as mine when it comes to Google. Though
Google no doubt was created by man, it currently,
on its own, organizes itself using the energy
that it has, which is the power from the power
grid.
So, is Google alive? I'm going to break some
rules here and venture a cautious yes. And
you are welcome to comment on my idiocy in
the comments.
Now there are some people who say that they
value all individual living organisms just
because they are alive. To those people I
say mehhh. You don't really believe that.
I made a point this morning to not brush my
teeth.
Yeah, how is that related?
But because I didn't brush my teeth today,
there are approximately a hundred billion
living organisms in my mouth right now. The
question becomes: do all those organisms have
value, and if they do, do I have a responsibility
not to kill all of them? Uh, the answer is
no, they don't have value, and I don't care
if they live or die, 'cause my breath's stinky.
And neither do you, at least, I hope, because
you also kill billions of them every single
day. John, I will see you on Wednesday.
GLaDOS: The only thing you've managed to break
so far is my heart.